I know this is Dr. Kevin Connors and we're going to go over your right tutorial how to use this machine that we're
deciding to every desire to help you in every way. So let's follow through this. This video is also
going to be on your computer itself. So if you need to review on how to use this, this is going to be
placed on your desktop of your right computer. So that will be a nice little benefit too. The pictures
that we use in this video, see these pictures here, are in the back of your binder. So your new
patient binder has these pictures and it's as easy as pie. It's really easy. We tell people if you've
never used a computer, it's going to be a little challenging. If you know how to use a computer
well enough to email somebody, it's you're going to be just fine. So it's fairly easy to learn.
So this picture here says there's some things that you need to know about the back of your right
machine. There's fuses that are extra fuses taped to the back of your right machine. There may be
an extra transistor. That's the thing with the little fold on it here. That is hot glued to the back
of your right machine. And then there's two transistors that the yellow arrow goes to.
That can heat up and burn out. That's why there's an extra one. But quite honestly, I may be replaced
a dozen of these in a dozen years. And it's because people used it not having it plugged into a
power search control or they had electrical storm or something like that. So that's where you'll burn
out a transistor. The other way that you'll burn out a transistor is if you run the thing without the
bulk plugged in. So don't do that. There is a child safety switch. If you're looking at the machine to
the right of the machine on the bottom, but not in any of the newer machines. So if yours is the
newest model, it does not have the child safety switch. We're able to get that taken off, which is very
nice. So if you have a little bit older, early 2017 model, and before, then they'll have a child
safety switch. Make sure that's toggled up. The front of your machine, the front of your machine has
power button on the left. The output control right next to it, which is always need to be all the way
correct to the clockwise direction. The bulb toggle, very, very important. It says bath or bulb.
Always have it in the bulb position if you're using the bulb. Make sense? Well, what's the bath for?
Well, there is a second apparatus that you could purchase that plugs into the bottom right-hand
corner of your machine that big little plug-in thing that you're not using. If you don't have the
bath apparatus, the bath apparatus is like an iron cleanse machine that helps pull
step out of your like a bucket of water that you would put your hands or your feet in.
There is an accessory toggle that is that says color one. You could toggle that either way because
you're not using a color one ground. Then the bulb is plugged into the center of the machine where
there's a black plug and a red plug that your bulb has on the plugs either a red or a black
end to it. You plug the red into the red and the black and the black. Pretty easy. Then on the far
right upper there's LED indicator lights and that has to do that the machine is ready. Now
it'll be a happy day in paradise for you when you're a little indicator lights burn out because that's
the most annoying thing about the entire right machine of those indicator lights. In nine for a long time
I actually put a piece of black tape over them to cover them up. They can burn out at
work and the machine is still running. So just so you know that is something to look for.
So the right setup you're going to plug in your computer. So your computer needs to be plugged into
the same surge protector that you're plugging in the right machine. So you want to use a surge
protector. So this is a high voltage machine that right is and you don't want it to be damaged by
an electrical failure or surges in electricity in your house for whatever reason. Plug the computer
into that also you should always have the computer plugged in and you should always run it plugged in.
So if you're not running it off the batteries computers use a whole you know produce like one tenth
the EMF's. So you always want to plug it in and use it off of home power. That you plug the USB
from the right machine into the USB port. Make sure you plug it into the USB port so that people
call and say it's not working. Is it plugged into the USB port? No sorry. So plug it into the USB
port and then you plug the bulb in. The bulb again is red to red, black to black and then you put the bulb
in your bed with you. So I've told you that I in our house I have the right machine the computer
itself is sitting on the bed side stand next to my side of the bed. Then we have the right machine
itself is underneath our bed because to be the lights that come out of the right front are the most
annoying. And when we moved our bedroom around I took the black tape off and cleaned it up but I put
the right machine under the bed. Therefore the wires that come out of the front of the right machine
will never get caught on somebody's foot and pulled out or something like that. And then so the the
wires come out of the right machine and they go behind my bed and they come up between behind my
headboard and the mattress and the bulb is always light in our bed. We make the covers over the top
of the bulb. You'll get used to it. So that when you turn on the right and it's going to be ready to go
you get under your covers. The bulb is already shining and you're ready to go and you're running
your program. So your daily use is just that. You're going to time to go to bed. You open up
the computer because you close it the night before. You open up the computer. You boot up the computer
so that the right computer turns on and you can see the little right icon on the desktop. Double click
on that right icon because that's the right program and you open up the right program. Then you go to your
folder. If you have to hit open home you can. If you hit open you'll go back to the folder
that you were last in and then you go to your folder. Now this is the first time you opened up
the right program. You'll want to hit open home and then you'll see a whole bunch of folders.
So remember your right machine you're going home with has well over a thousand maybe even two
thousand programs on it. But the majority of the time you're going to be using the programs that I
created for you. And I put it in a folder that has a a and your name so it'll come up first alphabetically.
So it should be the top folder in the program. Double click on the folder and then you'll see your
name under your name there. It'll come up Sunday by Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday and
whatever day it is today you click on that day. That will open up that day's program and then you
hit run and you run the program. It's literally that easy. But don't forget the next day.
Shut the computer. Once you hit run on the computer it sends the program to the right machine.
Literally you could disconnect the computer and walk away with it if you want.
The right would then continue to run that program until it times out. Now understand I wrote the
programs for you that are longer than a typical person would sleep. Typically I write eight to
nine to ten hour programs knowing that people are only going to be in bed seven six seven eight hours
because the end of what is going to recycle back in. I just want if you go to bed early and you're
going to read a book or watch some TV or something like that I want you to get as much in as possible.
So you don't have to be sleeping for this to work. Just run it. You're going to bed. You're going to be
in the vicinity of the right machine. Turn it on. Okay. Get used to just turn it on. It takes
an extra 30 seconds of the day. Believe it or not I've gotten people's rights back and I could tell if
you use it or not because there's a secret way for me to tell that. And I've had people not do well
and then look and see that they only run their right machine about one fourth of time. It's like
okay there's no excuses now. So make sure you turn it on every night. It's pretty easy. If you ever want
to pause it you could hit the pause button and then come back and you have to hit pause again to
unpause it but I tell you why are you going to do that? Don't do it. Just leave it running but I get
up to go to the bathroom. Then get up to go to the bathroom. You'll get those frequencies again.
So don't stop the machine. Don't open it up in the middle of the night and have to pause it.
Don't do that. Once you hit run at night before you go to bed it's running. Don't change it. Just
let it run. If you have to get on I have to get up and walk around for an hour. Well get up and walk
around for an hour then come back and lay down again. So do not stop it. Just run it. Now if you are
running a program in the day or let's say you hit, well it's Tuesday you actually hit Monday's program
by accident. Oh I just ran that last night. Then hit stop and go back to open to get back to the
file that you read or go to open home and then back to AA your program and go to Tuesday and have
run again. So you could use stop. So I tell people the top bar the the the only thing you're really
going to hit is open, run, stop and open home. Really that's what you're going to hit. That's all you're
going to use. Now you may during the day run some other files. That's great. So oh I got really bad
paint. My knee has been really hurting me. Run the paint program. Oh I just don't feel good. I feel
like I got a colder flu coming up. Run a cold and flu on coming program. This is a wonderful tool.
The biggest mistake I see with people with the right machine is they don't use it. So use it. Run some
of the other programs. Do the same thing. Go to open home. Look at the program you want to run.
Click on it. There's a whole bunch of different general use programs that you could use that can be
extremely beneficial for you. So use the right. There's no excuse. This should be your go to for
everybody in the house. Your child has a problem. Use does it ever is there a right program for that?
Run the right program. So we get the latest testimonials from people who say oh I read it by
planter about the planter awards program and by planter awards filler. Well that's fantastic.
Okay it's not going to cure everybody's planter awards but planter awards are a virus. So we
run the program. So make sure you use it. Common questions. Can I use other electronics? Can I watch
TV? Can I listen to the radio? Can I listen to you know by ipod while I yes you can. So you can
run other electronics while running the right. It may interfere with radio signals. We've had people say
that I don't run the radio in our bedroom but we've had people say it makes the you know something
go freaky with the radio. That's a possibility. But yes you can use other electronics. That thing
is going to interfere with the right frequency. Right? The right frequency might interfere with
something else but the biggest complaint we get if it's a complaint people say as they
they can get a static electricity shocks. Yes you can you're running frequencies. So if you're
getting a lot of shocks there could be a couple possibilities. Number one your house is very dry.
That's a possibility if you get a lot of static electric shocks with the right machine. Number two
you are very dry meeting your dehydrated. Make sure you're hydrated. Number three it can be just
it's just the the frequencies that's running at that time. So many times if it's running at a very
high frequency you're going to be more prone to static electric shocks. And number four we might need
to use a ground in your man. So just let us know if it continues as it becomes really aggravated.
And I will talk to you about possibly using some ground. Next question can we run night programs
during the day? Absolutely. So some people's programs I already wrote you some day programs run
those during the day or certainly run any other programs you will during the day. And other people I
did not write you yours. You know specific day programs you can run the night programs during the day
and understand your programs are not sequential. So do I have to run blood day and then Tuesday and
then Wednesday. What if I messed up and actually read Tuesday? When did I mess up the sequence? No
there's no sequence to them. So you can run a day program. I'm going to run blood day during the day
but I only read it for three hours. Well this is stop it. It's stop. So no problem with doing that.
Next question is it normal to feel achy or cold or flu is coming down after using the right?
Maybe yes and then what you got going on. So if we're doing a lot of kill programs,
what if you have Lyme disease or some other bacteria or something like that? That yes we don't want
to hurt you. We need to move the ball away. So if you're listening to this and you're a Lyme patient
you cannot hurt. That's my rule number one. So if you feel achy after using the right that we need
to put the ball button to the bed or move it farther away from you. For my cancer patients,
if you feel achy after using the right that's a good thing. Suck it up and keep
charging through because we're not hurt seed with the cancer patient. So we are killing cancer
cells and we need to do that. If you have any other questions about this make sure you contact us
or jump on our Zoom calls or whatever to get your questions answered. There's a whole trouble
shooting guide in the back of your binder. The biggest mistakes that we see that people make is
that it comes up a USB error. That's very common that the right frequencies will feedback to the
computer and it'll think that it doesn't have that USB connection. Sometimes you just need to unplug
the USB cable and plug it back in. Or the other mistake that we see people make is that they don't
power down their computer itself and reboot it enough. That's fine. I'm really bad at that.
So if I get that USB error, if I don't unplug the USB cable and plug it back in and it doesn't work
right away, then I got to reboot the computer. You'll get also run error messages where it thinks
it's still running. Even though it's not running, it'll say you have to stop the it's
running. It's still running. It'll tell you that the program's still running. Just hit okay and hit
stock and then hit and then run it again. So the whole idea is the whole problem is that we're running
frequencies. So when you're running frequencies, it can feedback to the computer and the computer
thinks it's stopped or thinks it's still running and you have to just reboot that.
The right program may state that there's time left on the program or the countdown on the timer
won't be accurate. You shouldn't be looking at any help because your rule number one was to as soon as
you hit run, you close the computer. So that shouldn't be an issue. Contact us or true right with any other
technical issues. Usually they're pretty easy to fix. If it's something with the right machine itself,
true right is the person to help you with that. If you send it back to us, we can fix it. We have
to send it to them. So that's a rare happening though. The machine I am at home is at the time of
this recording is I think six years old and it still runs great. My son's machine is six years old,
still runs great. My daughter's machine is at least that old still runs great. So
there's never really an issue. So great. I hope this was helpful. Make sure you look at the guide
in your binder as well. Thanks.